hello grammarians today i want to talk
to you about the idea of the perfect
aspect of verbs and what that means is
that it's not you know beyond reproach
or that it's like beautiful and shiny no
no what it means is really that whatever
we're talking about whatever action we
are talking about is complete
so we use the perfect aspect in all
tenses to illustrate when something has
been completed prior to the present
moment so when we talk about the present
we're talking about one point
now but when we're using when we use
aspect it enables us to talk about a
period between then and now you're
speaking in the now referring to a point
previous so we could say
using the perfect the way you form the
perfect is you simply add
have
and then you use the past form of the
verb
so if my assignment for example were to
wash some dishes when the dishes were
complete i would say to the person that
told me to wash the dishes i have
washed the dishes
so i'm using the present tense form of
to have and the past tense form of
washed so as with the progressive aspect
the thing that changes is the helper
verb
this part the main verb does not change
it remains in the past tense even if
we're talking about the present or the
future the part that changes
is have
so if we want to put this story in the
past
you know talk about a period that is
then but also
say that we wash the dishes at a period
before then right a time before the
moment in the past that we're talking
about if that makes sense we would say
i
had
washed the dishes
and if we want to talk about something
in the future
that happens before that future moment
but after now we would use the future
perfect to say
i
will
have washed the dishes
and that's what the perfect aspect
allows us to do it allows us to travel
backward in time a little bit extra it
allows us to say oh well before the
point in this story that i'm mentioning
this thing was already completed so the
perfect enables us to say here is a
thing that happened in the past here is
a verb action that has completed in the
past prior to the moment i'm talking
about
so to recap the perfect refers to
something finished you can learn
anything dave it out